Brady I'm actually going to talk about
the thermionic valve but everybody
recognizes a valve like this they might
find on their plumbing system at home as
if the valve is closed then no water
flows and if it's open then I can can
see through it and if it's half open
then only half the flow goes through and
of course what would be really nice is
to be able to have an electronic version
of that if we think about what was
happening a hundred years ago or just
over a hundred years ago the age of the
electrical world if you like obviously
motors were around lamp bulbs and so on
we could switch them on and off but we
couldn't control the amount of
electricity going through them easily
something like Edison who would
obviously building lamp bulbs he was
quite intrigued as to why his lamp bulb
was going black on one side and not on
the other something strange was
happening inside the actual device
itself and point of fact what he was was
carbon atoms were actually heading
towards one side of the filament if you
like the very first particle accelerator
and of course people like JJ Thompson
took those ideas on and started to try
and investigate where what were these
mysterious particles and and rays and so
on one of the early experiments with
something called the Maltese Cross
experiment and I've got one of those
just here if you can can see this one
this is a modern version of the Maltese
Cross experiment but clearly it's it's
so much identical to the original we can
see an anode just in there is made out
of metal and it's powered by a high
voltage which is coming from the from
the power supply we also have a cathode
we eventually find out that the the
actual raised the becoming from the
cathode so called cathode rays are
indeed electrons and of course that's
the breakthrough that JJ Thompson
made so what's what's gay we need the
the light off if you can manage that
baby yeah they can do that we can't see
the the cathode directly but we can see
the light that's given off by the
cathode but what's happening is the
electrons are boiling off and they're
being accelerated by the electric field
towards the towards the anode now if
we're very careful we can turn up the
attention supply and now we can we can
see the green glow the phosphorescence
of which is caused by the high-speed
electrons or we're seeing the ones that
have missed the target and are hitting
the hitting the phosphor we get a shadow
of that of that cross why it's called
the maltese cross experiment why they
put a maltese cross in the first place
we don't we don't really know the little
interesting thing that we discover is
that if I take a little magnet and point
it towards the beam then the magnet
deflects the electrons in the beam
remember that these devices become the
forerunners of things like the cathode
ray tube which used to be in televisions
until a few years ago where we actually
used the magnetic field to deflect the
the electron beam and caused a spot to
travel about on the on the phosphor
that's making our our picture okay well
we've got to we've got to come forward a
few years and think about a chap called
John Ambrose Fleming who was in point of
fact the very first professor of physics
in 1881
here at Nottingham however he only
stayed one year he went off to do other
things like invent the thermionic diode
what he discovered was that he could
make a device which only conducted
electricity one way because if I
connected the anode and cathode around
the wrong way then we wouldn't get
anything so current only flows through
this device in one in one direction what
was even more useful it was something
that chap called lee deforest
came up with in 1906
little diagram of a thermionic diodes on
the on the board already written we can
see the the filament we can see the
cathode we can see the anode what lee
deforest did was put in an extra
so-called control grid as he called it
and by controlling the voltage we'll
call it controlling the voltage on that
input there he could be found that he
could control the current that was
flowing through through the diode in
fact the important thing is a very small
change in the voltage produces a large
change in current we have an active
device which will increase the power of
a signal and so that really is the vital
breakthrough so obviously we connect the
heater up to a voltage and this heats up
the the cathode and what would happen is
that the electrons jump out of the
surface of that of that heated heated
metal but obviously soon return to it if
we apply an anode voltage a large anode
voltage then these electrons get swept
up along and towards towards the anode
so hence the flow of the electrons is
always towards the the higher voltage
however notice that the current flow I
is conventionally in the opposite
direction is one of the things our
forefathers got wrong in a sense which
is confused confused as to ever since
really is that they the electron flow is
opposing the actual conventional current
flow if we put a voltage on our on our
input that disturbs the electric field
caused by this anode to cathode field
and effectively what what happens now
instead of the electrons flowing flowing
up they get they get stopped and an
obviously fall back and so on so we can
control that we look at what a real
valve is this is a this is a this is
quite a coming to me t1
this this device itself would be used as
a radio transmitter valve and in point
of fact of something like this is is
still in use because though vowels were
superseded by solid-state devices from
the 1960s and so on onwards and a
transmitting valve like this is still
the most efficient efficient and
cost-effective way of transmitting so
even in our MRI scanner 3t Current in
our life scanner we actually have a
valve amplifier and because it's the
only way you can cost-effectively get 25
kilowatts of RF power well the glass is
is of course there to keep the vacuum in
so inside we have a complete vacuum and
it's the vacuum is sucked out through
this and sealed through that little that
little spigot and it has to be that big
because of course it gets very hot and
so we need to conduct the heat away why
the vacuum because if we have if we had
if we have anything in our molecules in
inside there then the electrons will
will scatter off and we won't get we
won't get any any flow at all there are
still people around who swear by valves
particularly audio files they love to
use valve amplifiers and as though this
is a little bit more of an antique
device down here again if you switch the
lights off Brady let's do that you can
see the the valves glowing glowing away
these these are amplifying the valves at
this end and then this is the output
stage valves and this is actually the
rectifier diode and being used to
rectify the power supply this is a this
is an audio amplifier so connect it to a
loudspeaker and feed it with a signal
from your record player and you will get
sound out